extracting and transforming energy
requires land wind farms coal mines
biofuel plantations how can we evaluate
and compare the diverse land use
footprints of energy technologies one
simple metric is power density the rate
at which energy is extracted per unit of
land one common measure of power density
is watts a primary energy per square
meter of land surface here is a rough
comparison of the power densities
various energy technologies first note
that this graph has a log scale a
plantation that produces 10 tons of dry
biomass per hectare per year has a power
density of half a watt per square meter
while a coal mine that sprawls over 25
square kilometres and produces say 30
million tons of coal per year has a
power density of a thousand watts per
square meter this is a factor of two
thousand times more than the biofield
plantation second note that the
uncertainties and the numbers are huge
and the different studies disagree
quantifying land-use impacts is
inherently more ambiguous than
quantifying air emissions toxics or
greenhouse gases power density tells you
nothing about how long the activity can
go on for about the total size of the
energy resource the biofield plantation
can in principle keep producing forever
whereas the coal mine has to keep
growing or moving to keep accessing new
coal so if you look over a long enough
time horizon it would take less land to
produce energy for biofuels than coal
but that time horizon is very long
finally note that the power density of
renewable sources is generally much less
than the power density of fossil fuels
or nuclear power this means that if
humanity moves from fossil fuels to
renewables in order to protect the
climate there will be an increase in the
energy systems land footprint we need to
think about the environmental and social
impacts of disturbing more land
I say disturbing because land is never
used up rather it is disturbed or
impacted by various human activities
this is what we mean when we say land
use how does land use matter land is the
ultimate finite resource land use plays
a central role in mediating many of the
and environmental impacts of energy
extraction and of other human activities
like agriculture or urbanization impacts
on water endangered species and
societies are all linked to land use to
see what the numbers mean is helpful to
think about what fraction of land would
be required to run a future energy
system using various energy technologies
suppose the world will use 30 terra
watts of energy late this century and
suppose it will be powered entirely by
biofuels or the power density of 1 watt
per square meter this would require 30
10 to the 12 square meters the land area
of the planet is only 150 10 to 12
square meters so to run the whole energy
system on biofuels will take about 20
percent of the total land surface of the
earth more than we now use for cropland
a huge environmental impact
solar power has much higher power
densities the typical power density of
current solar power systems in
reasonably good locations is about 10
watts per square meter thus the total
land requirement of an all solar system
would be more like 2% of the Earth's
surface wind power is a more complicated
story it looks like the power density
very large wind farms is limited to
about one watt per square meter however
the wind turbines and associated access
roads and power lines take up a very
small fraction of land inside the wind
farm if you count the entire area of the
wind farm as disturbed then the power
density of wind farms is roughly the
same as biofuels but if you count only
land directly occupied then wind farms
have a power density 100 times larger
there's no right answer because there's
no unambiguous metric of what it means
to occupy land the configuration of land
use particularly whether the footprint
is diffuse or concentrated plays a large
role in determining impacts a
concentrated development that occupies a
single square block may have less impact
than a diffuse activity that uses the
same total footprint spread over lots of
little footprints wind farms and natural
gas fields for example are diffuse while
coal mines and biomass plantations are
concentrated determining what you think
about the land use footprint of
dispersed energy production like natural
gas or wind power depends on how you
think about the impacts on the land
adjacent to the wellhead or turbine
energy analysts often ignore land
footprint because they're hard to
quantify
human judgment and values enter in
figuring out what to count is footprint
one of the reasons I personally take
nuclear power seriously is that it has a
very small land footprint and I happen
to put a lot of value on leaving more
land undisturbed you may have different
views while I hope I have done in this
lecture is convinced you that we must
consider land footprints seriously and
thinking about the future energy systems
that are going to produce energy at the
scale necessary to eliminate carbon
dioxide emissions and power a high
energy late 21st century society